avant d'annoncer la fermeture de
maternelle 4 ans pour regarder toutes
nos options et moi dans mon esprit ça
reste à faire
Bernard drinville qui la semaine
dernière commentait la décision
le projet en tout cas d'une commission
scolaire d'un centre de service de
réduire le nombre de maternelles 4 ans
pourquoi compte tenu du manque
d'enseignants du manque de personnel
puis c'est dans d'autres régions c'est
le cas aussi il y a la question de
l'argent aussi mais il y a la question
philosophique depuis le début est-ce que
c'est une bonne idée de créer un réseau
parallèle d'une certaine façon au CPA
avec nous deux personnes qui connaissent
très bien le sujet et j'ai broyé
psychologue spécialiste de la réussite
ce royaume
bonsoir vous êtes évidemment résolument
pour les maternelles 4 ans en fait vous
avez peut-être un des pères des
maternelles 4 ans Jean-François
chiccoine pédiatre que vous connaissez
aussi vous êtes contre les maternel 4
ans non pas contre les maternelles 4 ans
mais oui mais surtout pour les CPE mais
on va vous entendre et j'ai broyer on va
voir un tableau et Jean-François chiccan
on va voir un tableau monsieur Legault
rêvait de 5000 classes de maternelle 4
ans et on a baissé un peu les attentes à
2600 compte tenu des difficultés dont je
parlais là on est il y a
1584 classes ouvertes actuellement
et j'ai droyé vous vous dites on
continue il faut pas lâcher
continue parce que c'est une des c'est
une des réalisations les plus
importantes des variables les plus
importantes concernant pour la réussite
scolaire des jeunes vulnérables au
niveau des jeunes de 4-35 ans donc ça on
avait des données de recherche solide
pour étoffer ça lorsqu'on a fait la
proposition ce modèle-là l'autre élément
c'est que les talons or et ça monsieur
chicane avec ça les talons or au niveau
de l'intervention pour des jeunes
vulnérables c'est d'intervenir tôt de
faire la prévention mais d'intervenir
tôt or en ce qui concerne toute la
question de la réussite éducative c'est
exactement la même chose donc ça prendra
peut-être plus de temps les développer
mais c'est un des ajouts les plus
importants de ces dernières années pour
faire une différence au niveau de la
réussite éducative des jeunes
vulnérables ok alors vous il faut
surtout pas reculer devant des
difficultés Jean-François Chicoine
pourquoi vous dites que il faut pas il
faut pas se disperser
parce qu'on n'a pas encore consolidé
notre réseau de CPE
vers 2000 2005-2010 on voyait que
l'évaluation des CPE nous montrait que
plusieurs étaient bons mais pas tout
suffisamment excellent surtout dans les
milieux
défavorisés
on a eu
la possibilité d'un développer ça s'est
malheureusement pas fait partout il
accès qui est difficile moins à Montréal
plus en région on sait que pour amener
un enfant vers la vie et pas juste vers
le futur vers sa vie vers le présent on
a besoin et là on est d'accord avec les
talons or si je peux dire
on a besoin de d'une suite éducative dès
l'âge de 6 mois un an pour les enfants
des milieux à risque ou les enfants qui
ont des besoins particuliers jusqu'à
l'âge de 5 ans c'est important le milieu
soit excellent que ce soit prolongé pour
moi c'est un milieu de vie les CPE et
c'est surtout un milieu qui me permet
d'intervenir sur les principaux
déterminants que je retrouve dans les
familles
néo-migrantes défavorisée ou chez les
enfants qui ont des besoins particuliers
les enfants prématurés c'est à dire
des éducatrices formées on l'espère de
mieux en mieux et c'est quelque chose
qui qui s'en vient de mieux en mieux des
éducatrices formées qui sont capables de
répondre à leur sécurité affective à
leur apaisement et qui sont capables de
leur permettre de jouer parce que pour
réussir dans la vie il faut apprendre à
jouer et beaucoup d'enfants malheureux
ou de milieu défavorisés ne savent pas
jouer n'ont pas eu le temps de jouer et
je pense que les CPE sont très très
habilités pour le faire vers l'âge de 4
ans ce qui n'empêche pas des activités
de stimulation en plus des activités
en position avec la maltraitance si vous
connaissez si vous connaissez moins de
Romain le tout nouveau programme du
préscolaire cycle 4 ans 5 ans qui vient
de rentrer en vigueur il s'est produit
en 2020 c'est axé sur le jeu ça porte
spécifiquement sur des dimensions qui
sont relationnelles des dimensions même
au niveau de la veille à l'écrit de
l'éveil au langage et des interventions
spécifiques de la prévention globale de
la prévention ou de l'intervention
spécifique mais l'autre élément qu'on
oublie toujours là vous venez de parler
des communautés culturelles ou des
familles peut-être ne parlent pas encore
le français la loi 101 s'applique en
maternelle parce que la maternelle
quatrain ça fait partie d'une école donc
moi immigrants ce qui n'est pas le cas
en ce moment
35 % des places actuellement pour les
jeunes en service de garde et se mast 35
% le y a encore beaucoup de garde en
milieu familial et autres qui sont qui
sont qualités mais c'est vraiment le
tien seulement des gens qui sont assezpe
mais la question de la loi 101 et que la
possibilité
elle s'applique et le fait moi par en
arrivant j'ai immigrant j'ai une place
dans une maison d'éducation qui
s'appelle une école c'est de l'immersion
en français c'est gratuit et si j'ai un
jeune que certains besoin particulier en
plus une forme d'intervention dans
l'ensemble des ressources de l'école
écouter les deux réseaux sont bons mais
moi pour avoir passé près 50 ans en
adaptation scolaire si un parent me
demande mon jeune a des difficultés de
langage en retard de développement en
simus faire la maternelle 4 ans ou de
continuer en service de garde en milieu
familial je lui dis probablement
maternelle 4 ans Jean-François docteur
répondait à ce qu'est sur l'argument du
français mais aussi sur
avec avec
des apprentissages oui avec une
travailleuse sociale et des appels dans
les CPE ont réussi à mettre
beaucoup d'enfants en CPE parce qu'on
est d'accord là-dessus monsieur Royer et
moi il faut qu'ils y aille alors je
pense que le fait de leur apprendre que
dans le bien commun québécois il y a des
CPE qui sont de bonne qualité ça fait
partie du travail des intervenants comme
pédiatre c'est très très facile pour moi
d'intervenir sur des problèmes de santé
je parle par exemple des retards ou des
troubles de langage des problèmes
moteurs et de différentes conditions
pour un enfant en CPE parce que j'ai des
services du CSC la psychoéducation
l'éducation spécialisée l'orthophonie la
travailleuse sociale je n'ai aucun
service pour les enfants de 4 ans et on
comprend actuellement c'est difficile
d'en avoir pour des enfants aux
primaires et aux secondaires j'ai pas
suffisamment d'espace pour les faire
jouer dans beaucoup d'écoles or ça
devient difficile pour moi et pour nos
équipes d'intervenir aussi très
important les maternelles quatrains
supposent qu'on va à un service de garde
vers 2h30 3h30 donc on est encore
basculer dans un autre groupe et il y a
pas de maternelle 4 ans l'été et nous on
a besoin de quelque chose de continuer
souvent aussi l'été où on met les
enfants de famille néo immigrants qui
travaillent l'été dans un camp de jour
une bonne raison c'est une bonne
question et j'ai dit ça
mais pour des enfants de 4 ans écoutez
vous avez déjà à 4 ans vous avez des
enfants qui sont capables de participer
entre autres ou toute l'ensemble des
activités les activités de loisirs sont
organisées durant l'été c'est d'avoir de
toute manière au niveau des services de
garde mais
cette dimension là et moi j'essaie
pendant 2 ans toute la pandémie avec
quelqu'un un comité qui était formé tous
les ordres professionnels en éducation
écoutez ça veut dire pratiquement
l'unanimité cette question là d'être
capable d'offrir des services dans un
environnement continue sur 200 jours
auprès de jeunes dans un environnement
comme la maternelle 4 ans on prend des
gens qui présentent certaines
difficultés parce que même si les
ressources sont limitées les
professionnels étaient sur place aussi
donc la plus value qu'on peut avoir
l'emporte amplement sur la question du
gardiennage ou des interventions
dans le fond qui peut être fondamental
est-ce qu'on a les moyens de bien
développer les deux réseaux en même
temps et je dois y aller 30 secondes
là-dessus et docteur Chico en après
moi c'est une question politique
probablement mais en ce qui me concerne
c'est un passage obligé parce que j'ai
35 % des gars 20 et 22% des filles qui
arrivent en maternelle en situation
d'une réhabilité présentement et c'est
vraiment le type d'intervention qui
m'apparaît la meilleure donc on ne peut
pas ne pas dire on n'a pas les moyens en
interviendra pas les deux raisons ont le
place mais pour prévenir les internautes
c'est vraiment la maternelle 4 ans qui
m'apparaît à privilégier docteur
on a augmenté les salaires et puis les
niveaux de formation des éducatrices
malheureusement avec la pandémie c'est
une sur trois qui est formée
actuellement dans nos CPE au lieu de 2
sur 3 qui était la règle et ça devrait
revenir et je pense que c'est des
occasions de carrière extraordinaires
avec un deck pour énormément de gens on
manque de professeurs aux primaires au
secondaire on manque d'espace moi je
pense que le plein air les grands
espaces les places de jeux avec des
éducatrices qui qui prennent du temps de
proximité avec les enfants c'est un
métier qui est différent je suis un
professeur je suis capable d'évaluer des
enfants en situation de jeu mais
j'aurais pas la patience de ma psychoé
éducatrice pour passer trois heures avec
eux très bien le débat va se poursuivre
il y a des il y a des paramètres
économiques aussi qui vont jouer on
verra ici broyer psychologue qu'on
connaît bien grand spécialiste de la
réussite docteur Jean-François Chicoine
pédiatre qu'on connaît aussi bien merci
beaucoup de nous avoir parlé bonjour à
vous deux merci ça fait évoluer ça nous
fait réfléchir